you should learn how and when you can
break the rules MH and then at the end
of the day you you choose where you can
break the rules is that not does that
sound crazy no it doesn't sound crazy it
does sound like you can weather a the
fin the financial storm but you got but
you can only get there if you don't care
if you're afraid all the time you'll
never make money you'll never do
anything it's tough not to care I went
through three years of watching not say
anything and not earn a dollar cuz you
were waiting to get jobs on a fake TV
show that never happened and they were
like I can't have an opinion about
anything because I won't get on this
thing that isn't real it's not even real
anymore they're not even making these
shows these people are eating on the
street they have their [__] on
Craigslist and for three years they were
fearful and afraid of everything so my
whole point is that you shouldn't be
afraid to just
live